(rhythmic music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the lifelong podcast where (laughs).
- The lifelong podcast?
I mean, that's quite a commitment.
I mean, do you wanna do this
- What else are we gonna do?
until we die?
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for their entire lives.
I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting,
we are talking about
some of the habits of successful people.
Now, and I'm not talking
about like that book,
- [Together] "The Seven
Habits of Successful People."
- We're talking about things
that you may or may not
have ever thought about.
We're kind of talking about
the weird secret habits
of successful people.
- Yeah, because just the normal habits
of successful people, that's boring.
I mean, we wanna go
strange, but I do think
that there's gonna be
some takeaways from this.
They may not be direct to
what we're talking about,
they may be the opposite of
or maybe you do wanna jump into a pool
and almost drown yourself, I don't know,
we'll have to find out.
But sometimes it's just
helpful to take a step back
and evaluate is there any new practice
that I can incorporate into my life?
Some new helpful habit
that might become the key
to accomplishing
something, you know, like.
- We're kind of over
promising at this point.
I don't think anybody, does
anybody listened to our podcast
so that they can become
successful or do they listen,
I kind of feel like people
listen to our podcast to escape
from thinking about success
and things like that.
- This was your idea.
- (laughs) Yeah, just,
only because I thought
it would be interesting to talk about.
So you can do something
like sweep up your child's art project
that they just dropped on the ground.
And guess what, people do-
- That's not a habit.
- No, people, I'm saying
people listen to "Ear Biscuits"
while doing other things.
And so for the person who's sweeping up
your child's art project
that you accidentally broke.
First of all, don't tell them,
they're gonna forget about it.
- Did this happen to you today?
- No.
Maybe you'll wanna become more successful
from listening to this, but
that's not the intention.
The intention is to have an
interesting conversation.
- But listen, maybe
we'll discover something
that is the exact opposite.
Maybe you need to practice
to help you accomplish less
and enjoy life more.
Yeah, I'm promising big on this, man.
This is big.
- Well then you better deliver.
- I'm not backing down at all.
Today, we're gonna look at
habits of successful people
that are strange
and may or may not have
contributed to their success
or their wellbeing or their genius
or their fame.
But maybe there's something in it for us.
I'm just saying, let's
approach it with an open mind.
Maybe there is some things-
- Oh, I approach all
things with an open mind.
- Maybe there's something
that can revolution-
- My middle name is Open Mind.
- Well, that would be two names.
Revolutionize our experience.
You know, I, listen.
- Well, and I gotta say,
I gotta go ahead and say
preemptively that
at least three of these are things
that I was already zeroing in on.
But I think maybe this is gonna
take me to the next level.
Again, I'm not saying
it so that you'll do it.
- I picked all of these
because they sounded crazy,
not knowing that you did any of them.
- Well, I'm doing three of them.
- So that kind of adds up.
For what, I don't know
exactly why you're listening.
I think Rhett and I have
different ideas today
of what will keep you listening,
but as long as you keep listening
and as long as you buy
stuff from our sponsors,
just kidding, not
kidding, but we're happy.
Just hang out.
- We're gonna get to
that in a second though,
but you know what, something
pretty monumental is happening.
There was, we have a four-way group text
with the two of us and our wives.
And in that group text this
morning, I think, well,
I think maybe it was a text
from your wife to my wife
who was like, "Hey, you know, today
is our 10-year anniversary
of being in Los Angeles?"
And I was like, "No, it's not." (laughs)
It's not today, it's two days from now.
And I was like-
- So you knew the actual date?
- Well, because-
- The reason why she said that
is because something
popped up on her, you know,
it was either Facebook or
one of those Google Photos or
something where it's like,
"10 years ago today, this was happening."
- Well, here's how I know, because-
- And she ended up being two days early.
- Me and you, of course, drove
across the entire country.
We got to Los Angeles
one day before our wives and
children showed up on a plane.
And I have a picture that I took
from the balcony of the
apartment that we rented.
And there's a date on that.
March 11th, 2011.
And then Jessie was like, "Well,
did we come the next day?"
And then she brings up her phone,
and she finds the video that
she took in the RDU airport
when they were all getting
ready to get on the plane,
and she goes around with a phone
and she asks all five kids.
- [Jessie] All right, guys,
tell me what we're doing.
- Oh, a plane just took off!
- "What do you guys think,
where are we going?"
And she starts with Lily.
So this is 10 years ago, so
Lily was seven years old.
- Almost eight.
And it was just, it's so crazy.
- Four weeks away from being eight.
Like, when I think about how
long we've been in Los Angeles.
- Oh, I know.
- I'm just like,
it doesn't feel like
we've been here that long.
- But then when you see our children.
- I watched the video, and yeah,
I was thinking the same thing.
I was like, "When we moved here."
First of all, you know, we
rented furnished apartments.
We didn't move everything,
We kind of did this
like staggered approach
to kind of ease into it,
and that way, when we left,
we could tell our family and
friends that, you know what?
- This might not be permanent.
Just six months.
- Our furniture's still in our homes.
Of course, we were thinking,
"We gotta make this happen."
We, you know, in success,
we're gonna stay out there.
- Or not success. (laughs)
That was.
- Yeah.
- That's what you thought,
and I was too scared to
think that at that point,
but, yeah, I really didn't
think of it as like,
"We're doing that thing where
you move to a new city."
It was like, "We're going,
and we're doing this.
We're making this show.
And we just happen to have
to be in this city to do it.
And this is, this is.
It does feel like some dreams
coming true type of thing."
- And that kind of makes-
- But there was so much
going on that it wasn't
just about relocation.
- Well, that's why the kids didn't say
we're moving to California,
that's why Lily was like,
"We're gonna California."
And okay, now, did you notice that.
So it's so amazing how
indicative of their personalities
all of them are in this video.
So you got Lily.
- [Jessie] Lily, what are we doing?
- We're about to get on
a plane to go to Atlanta,
and after that, we're gonna
get on a plane to California.
- [Jessie] How do you feel about it?
- Okay.
- It was like, kind of like,
she's gonna answer the
questions, she's gonna engage,
she's gonna be like, we're
going so and so and so.
And then they go to Lincoln,
and he's got this funny look on his face.
And Jessie's like, "How do you
feel about traveling today?"
And he was like, "I don't
know what that means."
- [Jessie] Hey, Lincoln.
- Oh, here comes my mom with
the Cinnabon cinnamon rolls.
- [Jessie] Tell me what your
thoughts are on this move.
- I don't know what that means?
(laughing together)
- Yeah. And then she goes to Locke,
and Locke is standing up,
turned away from the camera.
And you know why he's doing that?
'Cause he was, first of
all, he's a challenger,
but he was very upset about moving.
He did not want to leave North Carolina.
And in fact, in the first couple of weeks
that we were in Los Angeles, he said,
"I would rather be a door knob."
That's why one of his famous quotes
is I would rather be a
doorknob than be in California.
I don't know how, why he thought.
But did you know, and so
do you notice in the video
where Jessie's, he's facing away,
and then he says something
like we're gonna go,
and Jessie's like,
"We're gonna go see
your dad in California.
And he says something like,
"I'm gonna insult my dad."
- I'm gonna insult you guys in the camera.
- [Jessie] No, no, no, no, no, no.
We're gonna be respectful.
Are you excited about this trip?
- No.
Actually, I'm not.
- [Jessie] And why is that?
- Oh, it's pretty normal.
- [Jessie] Pretty normal. Okay.
- (laughs) Or he said something like that,
and then she turns
around, he turns around,
and he's just so upset about it.
And of course, Shepherd and,
I mean, Lando was like
fresh from the womb.
It seemed like.
- [Jessie] Lando,
how do you feel about us
moving to Los Angeles?
- [Member] Lando, do this.
Can you show your trick?
- [Jessie] Let me see your trick, Lando.
- [Rhett] He was so little.
- Yeah, he was one.
- He's one.
That's fresh from the womb in my book.
- Ah.
- [Jessie] That is very impressive.
- [Member] That's kind of how I feel too.
- But she panned to Shepherd, and he was,
she would tell him what to
say, and then he would say it.
- [Jessie] Shepherd, where are we going?
- And then visiting my daddy.
- [Jessie] Okay, and where is your daddy?
What state is he in?
- California.
- [Jessie] Yes, California.
- He was super cute.
(Rhett laughs)
Is that all the kids? Do we?
That's it. That's all the kids.
Yeah. That's all the
ones we brought with us.
We don't talk about the ones
we left in North Carolina.
They're currently being
raised by another family.
- I mean, their lives are
defined by here. You know?
Their whole experience
has been defined by.
- How does that make you feel?
- I feel good about it.
- Well, the answer to that question is
- [Together] I don't know what that means.
(Rhett laughs)
I don't know.
What are you, what do you want me to do?
Like develop thoughts and
responses to questions.
- I don't know what that means.
- I don't (laughs).
- Yeah, but 10 years, man.
10-year anniversary in Los Angeles.
Like I said, it just went by so fast.
But I do think about it from
the perspective of the kids.
It's like, "Yeah, we
made this choice because
of what we were doing and
what we wanted to do."
And the effect was our
kids are from California.
I mean, that's how they think about it.
- And they're doing just fine.
You're doing great.
- Yeah. I think they are.
I mean, they're doing great.
They're doing great. They're doing great.
No, they are doing great.
It's just, when I think about
how they're doing right now,
I still think about the fact
that they're not yet back in school.
- Yeah. They've got their challenge.
- I want them to be back in
school as soon as possible.
Not because I'm tired of
dealing with them at home,
online school.
I'm just saying they're
tired of online school.
They're the ones who are tired of it.
- 10 years, man.
Congratulations. Let's celebrate.
Let's celebrate by reassessing
our lives and seeing
if there's something else
we can incorporate into it.
Some new practice that's
gonna change everything
or nothing because that's
not why you're listening.
- Right.
But first let's see
if we can get people to buy
that hoodie you're wearing.
- Okay, let me give it a shot.
I'm wearing this hoodie.
It's,
it's got that tie-dye think going on.
It's a,
it's a cool color.
It says, it has Mythical logo right there.
You want to rep your boys.
You want to be warm.
- So this is a subtle promo.
- You want to put your hoodie on.
- I get it.
You're kind of trying to
get them to make a decision.
You're not making the decision for them.
- Mythical.com.
Just comes in this teal color,
and it comes in a purplish hue.
- We call it crystal wash.
We had one that was like gray and black.
And now we've got these pastel colors.
- Put the hood on.
Hood goes all the way over
the head and the ears.
- You can wear while Easter egg hunting.
Or you can just wear it
by just while hunting.
- Now I'm wearing this
in order to promote it.
And I might, I don't know
what we're gonna talk about.
I might sweat.
I'm actually sweating a little bit.
I'm just go ahead and
tell you, but I might do,
it might turn into one
of those stink sweats,
depending on what we talk
about, where it's like,
"Wow, we're really
processing something, and."
- That makes you smell?
- I don't know. It makes
more stink come out.
I feel like when you really
are having a stress sweat,
and if that happens, then
this hoodie is gonna stink.
And then if you pick it up off the rack
and decide to put it on, it might stink
like that last hoodie that we
were modeling for mythical.com
and it stunk so bad.
- I'm not gonna throw
anybody under the bus.
- That wasn't me.
- Oh, I know.
- It was an extra large, I
wouldn't have put that on.
- There wasn't an actual
large, it was a large.
- Oh, maybe it was me.
- Here, no, it wasn't you.
- You know what my stink smells like?
- Unless you forget to wear
a deodorant for a full day
and wore that with no undershirt.
- This is a long ad.
I think we should start just doing it.
A podcast is just an ad.
We can talk for an hour.
- Just an ad. It's a whole new podcast.
It's just a side podcast.
- Do you think, would
anybody listen to that?
- Yeah. If it was good enough.
- Rhett and Link, add-cast.
- Just an ad.
- It's just, but it's not ad-reads.
It's just where we're talking about it.
We're talking about stuff.
'Cause I know you don't want
to listen to us read more ads
as a whole podcast, but promoting stuff.
- I think that Malcolm Gladwell podcast
that we had as a sponsor was just an ad.
You know the one that
was sponsored by Lexus?
- Yeah, but it was, and it wasn't.
We weren't selling something
the entire time directly.
And that's what my idea is.
- No, I'm saying that podcast
wasn't just an ad.
Not us selling, the podcasts.
It was a branded podcast.
- Oh, their podcast.
- It was just an ad.
- We did an ad for a
podcast that just ads.
- That was just an ad.
But I mean, it's Malcolm
Gladwell. It was interesting.
Anyway, rep your boys, mythical.com.
- Mythical.com.
- All right.
Let's just get started with Ben Franklin.
Why not? Let's go there.
- Take a naked air bath
is something you might
want to consider doing
on a daily basis because
Ben Franklin did that.
He would sit naked in the cold air
for half hour to an hour each morning
because he believed that cold water
was too much of a shock to the system.
- Whoa, hold on.
The way you put because
in there is misleading.
As opposed to doing it.
He believed that being in the
cold was gonna be helpful,
but he thought that
the air would be better
than the alternative
which would be cold water.
- I stand by what I said.
- I've talked about it
before on this podcast.
I told you that I was just
assembling the different parts
to make my own ice bath.
So the ice bath thing,
especially since Wim Hof, the Iceman,
kind of made this concept popular
is something that's in
the popular culture.
It's in the vernacular now.
Where people are doing the.
Athletes taking ice baths, whatever.
And so there's all these,
there's all this research
that suggests that first of all
saunas have all these health benefits.
So I'll go, let me go to
the hot side first, right?
- I'll go with you to the hot side now.
- All kinds of evidence is piling up
that people who spend
like four to seven days,
four to seven times a week,
and they studied all these guys.
And you know, it's very popular
in the culture of the men
in the like, you know, Sweden,
Norway, Scandinavian dudes,
very big for them to take, you know,
to go into saunas all the time.
A lot of times like public saunas,
and they followed,
there's multiple studies,
but one of the most famous
studies shows that people,
and again, this is kind
of a cultural thing.
So you know, more men were doing it.
So men are the ones
that have been studied,
but it probably affects
everybody in a positive way.
If you take a sauna, if
you take a sauna bath
of like 20 minutes or so at 175 degrees
four to seven times a week,
it has all these
incredible health effects,
like basically reduces
your all-cause mortality.
That's like dying of anything
by a large percentage.
Now you can go look up the
study to get the specifics.
I don't, I'm not, I don't
have it in front of me,
so I'm not gonna give you the specifics,
but it's also shown to have effects
on like mood, and you know
all kinds of things,
it makes you feel good.
So because of that, when we redid,
I've always loved being hot in general,
but when we redid the outdoor
area, I got a sauna installed.
'Cause I was like, "I'm gonna do this."
And I am basically doing it every night.
- Every night?
- If I'm at home, I'm doing it
definitely six times out of-
- 20 minutes?
- So first of all, I go for,
I have a, like a manual.
I have a timer, that's an
hourglass for 15 minutes,
and what I do is I go 15
minutes, and I get out,
and I'll talk about that,
'cause I'm coming back to Ben Franklin,
cool off, and then I go back
in for another 15 minutes.
So it ends up being about a half hour.
And currently I'm oscillating
between 195 and 205 degrees
is where I've gotten to you.
- Good gosh.
- Your tolerance builds up pretty fast.
So it's, when I first got
the thing, it was like 140.
I was like, "It's hot in here."
And then over the course of a few months,
I'm already over 200
degrees, so you can do it.
And you can feel, and
you'd begin to crave it.
But what I do is I go into the sauna,
then I get out of the sauna,
and I get into the pool,
which like last night it
was 46 degrees outside.
- 46 degrees.
Okay. So it might be 55 degrees?
- Low 50s. I think it was 52 degrees.
- In the pool, yes.
- Get the pool.
And I hang in the pool
for about five minutes.
- Good gosh, that's hard
to do the first time.
- You begin to crave it.
Like when we watched the octopus.
- My octopus teacher.
- He talked about how he
began to crave the cold.
I was like, "This dude's nuts."
- He said it took him a year,
but that water was frigid.
- He was way colder than I am.
And then I get out, and you
get back into the sauna,
and you get back into the sauna,
and it's like 205 degrees,
and it takes you about
five minutes to realize
that it's hot because
you were just so cold.
And then I go for 15 minutes,
and then I get out, and
I get back in the pool.
And then Ben Franklin, coming
back to the Ben Franklin,
I get out of the pool,
and I stand outside
for at least 10 minutes.
Last night, and I was
wet, out of the pool,
in a wet bathing suits, 46 degrees.
- But it's colder outside of
the pool than in the pool.
- But something about
coming out of the cold water
because of the heat transfer,
the water feels colder.
So I came out, and I just
stood next to the pool
and was like continuing
to listen to the podcast
that I had going.
And I just stood there for 10 minutes
before I began to feel uncomfortable.
It's revolution.
Have you noticed how I
haven't been wearing a jacket?
Like it'll be cold in our office,
and like me and you used to be like,
"Man, it's cold in here."
And we put on a layer.
We put on another jacket.
I've been thinking, "I'm hot."
Like I don't, I haven't worn a jacket.
I haven't worn a jacket
except maybe one time
when we went over to your house
to hang out in the
backyard the other night.
I wore a jacket.
I was like, "This is the first time
I've worn a jacket in a while."
Because my body has adjusted.
- Do you notice any other changes?
- I mean, I feel good,
but I don't know if that
has anything to do with it.
- You're not dead.
You didn't die of any cause.
- I feel good.
I haven't liked tested.
It's supposed to like
lower your blood pressure,
which I kind of had like
borderline blood pressure,
but I haven't tested that
in a couple of months.
I probably should test that.
- Well, you know, I'd be
interested to try that.
- I highly recommend this.
- I'm not coming over
to your house every day
to get your sauna.
- You should get one of those
infrared saunas, man. You can.
- I would have to try
it before I go all in.
- Well, you could just come over.
- But like being really cold
is something that I don't like.
That's why I'm liking
this Ben Franklin thing
because it's not a cold
shower or a cold pool plunge.
It's just cold air.
He's like, "You know what,
I'm gonna do something."
So he's sitting outside just naked
- Naked.
- in the cold
for an hour every morning.
- Well, and there are two things.
- He was onto something.
I mean, science has proven him correct.
And said, "You need to go further, Ben."
- Yeah, I wonder if he
understood what was happening.
If he just had a sense for it.
Because the science of this
is that what's happening with, when you.
So there's this stuff
called brown fat, right?
Which is like it's fat
that I guess under a
microscope looks darker.
- It's kind of already gravy.
- It's got more mitochondrial
elements to it or something.
And it isn't like, you can't see this fat.
It isn't like, "Oh, I
got a lot of brown fat,
and you can see that I'm
overweight," or whatever.
No, this is like fat
that kind of concentrates
in your neck and your shoulders.
And if you go back to like
pre-climate-controlled times,
so we're talking like
thousands of years ago,
everybody had way more brown fat,
and they were able to
regulate their temperature
and be cold and not really
have a big deal with it.
But now we've lost all our brown fat
because we've got hoodies and
jackets and climate control.
And so you don't need it.
And so you quickly lose it,
but there's all these studies that show.
In fact, there was one
study I was looking at.
There was these guys
who they slept, I think,
uncovered, out of a blanket,
and it's 68 degrees.
So like 68 degrees without
a blanket, you'd be like,
"Mm, this is a little uncomfortable,
a little too cold, right,
just a little bit too cold."
And these men did this for like six weeks,
and they all had some
very noticeable increase
in the amount of brown fat.
And what that ends up doing
is you become way more
tolerant of cold very quickly.
And then the moment they went
back to sleeping regular,
like within a few weeks
they lost the brown fat.
So you got to keep doing it.
But Ben Franklin had a bunch of brown fat
because he was doing
this, I'm telling you.
And he, you know, I mean, he
was way ahead of his time.
- Brown Fat Franklin.
- Yeah. That's his nickname.
- Brown Fat Ben Franklin, BF.
- Telling you, man, it's a light.
Just come over to my house, get in there.
My wife got in there for like
the first time last night
as a matter of fact, 'cause she was like,
"I just don't want to get in there.
I feel like I'm gonna faint or whatever."
I was like, "Let's just do 175."
Put her on 175.
She was in there for 15
minutes, sweating like crazy.
It's kind of sexy.
And then she came out, and
she was like, "I feel good."
I was like, "All right, we'll
do it again tomorrow night."
I'm gonna live forever.
- I'm not.
- (laughs) But.
Well, one of us is gonna
live longer than the other,
and they're gonna have to
keep doing this podcast.
'Cause you're committed to
doing it for our entire lives.
- All right, this is one
that came to mind immediately
when we started tossing around this topic.
And it's one that we keep coming back to
because we're fascinated about it.
Wear the same outfit every single day.
Of course, Steve Jobs, the
most famous example of this,
wore the same black.
Well, I don't think it was
the same black turtleneck.
He wore the same outfit, but
it was probably different.
- I think he had a closet
full of black turtlenecks.
- He probably had a closet
full of black turtlenecks,
blue jeans and New Balance sneakers, okay?
- Very particular choice.
- Of course it became his signature look
and a part of like the Apple aesthetic,
and his rationale when asked about it
was that he had a finite
capacity of brainpower
to make well-thought-out decisions.
And he wanted to minimize
his decision fatigue.
A minute more a day using his brainpower
to decide which t-shirt
to wear is less brainpower
he would have to think about his company.
- Many people have fallen into this,
because this has been out.
You know, everybody's known this
for the past 20 years or so.
- Obama did it.
You know, he only wore gray or black suits
except for that one time
that he wore the brown suit,
and everybody wanted,
- The tan suite.
- the tan suite,
wanted to talk about it.
And yeah, he told Vanity
Fair that he wants to,
he's trying to pare down decisions.
He said, "I don't want to make decisions
about what I'm eating or wearing
because I have too many
other decisions to make."
And just as a side note,
I totally relate to that.
We've asked Jenna just to,
if the crew is ordering food for us,
just get whatever we've gotten before
or whatever you know we'll like
because stopping and making a decision
- Stopping and making the
decision about what to eat.
- in the middle of making
a bunch of decisions.
So I do think this.
- It's demoralizing.
- Maybe this is like,
if your job is defined by
making constant decisions
would lead you to consider
something like this.
- Yeah, and the whole idea of a president.
I mean, first of all,
the president is gonna
wear a suit every day.
So that feels like, if
you have a closet full.
- Not after the pandemic, man.
He's gonna be wearing sweats
just like everybody else.
Biden gonna be wearing them sweats
like all the college basketball coaches
like we talked about.
They ain't going back to suits either.
- But the idea
that the president,
that doesn't really track for me
because they're already just,
they're just wearing a suit.
Like, it's not like, it's like,
"Yeah, I have a closet full
of suits and shirts and ties.
- Does Jimmy Fallon?
- And just put it on."
- All the late night show hosts.
I mean, they're just given a suit to wear.
I mean, if they don't like it,
I'm sure they won't wear it,
but they're not going through
and picking it out every day.
When you have to wear one every day.
- But this, but so.
- But I'm surprised that
it's not someone's job
to pick out the
president's suit every day.
I had to believe it was,
but the way that Obama talked about it,
it seemed like he wanted to simplify it.
'Cause I guess if you're wearing like,
"Oh, this is a tan suit.
Oh, you got me in this thing now."
Then even though you're
not making the decision
on what to wear, you're you
have veto power over it,
and you're still assessing it.
You're giving attention to it.
So it does make sense to
me, I guess that a president
would be tempted to allocate
mental resources to that.
- Okay.
- But you like the idea of publicity jobs.
- I've been, okay.
- I do not.
- I've been trying to land this for myself
for the past couple of months, okay?
And now when I say land this,
I don't mean get as specific
as same exact shirt.
He had multiple black turtle necks,
but they were all black turtlenecks,
and all blue jeans are the same color.
- Dennis The Menace.
- And all new Balance
Sneakers that look the same.
But I had been thinking about creating
like a couple of options.
Like if it is between X and
Y degrees in a certain day,
then I know what I'm
gonna wear is these jeans,
this shirt,
and maybe just a couple of
choices of shoes, right?
And then if it's a
little bit warmer, okay,
I'm gonna wear this t-shirt.
- Why?
- So for.
Now, for me, it has less to
do with decision fatigue.
The lunch decision is very
much about decision fatigue
because me and you
will be in a conversation about something.
We're making decisions.
Our job has largely become
making decisions, right?
We've got a little bit
better at kind of making it
where we're actually
doing creative things,
but we're managing a lot of things.
So,
- but for clothes.
- When Jenna comes into,
Jenna comes in and does that
it throws us off.
But in the morning, it's kind
of like, all right, it's not.
It's almost like a buffet.
Like I've got all the
clothes there, but for me,
my body type, it's my height.
And so it's very difficult,
90% of the clothes that I own,
once you wash them once,
I have to be really careful
about how I wash them
because shirts get too short
or shirts get, you know,
shirts that are long enough for two big,
shirts that are the right,
are tight enough or too short.
Pants, you can, it's just
being an unusual body type.
And so I've been on a
hunt for just a t-shirt
that I can reliably wear every single day.
Now you see, I wear the t-shirts
that we sell at the Mythical
store all the time, right?
Here's the issue with those shirts.
An extra large, it's a little bit bigger
than a shirt that I want to wear.
And a large looks perfect.
- Until you wash it.
- Until I wash it.
And our shirts don't
even shrink that much,
but I'm dealing with such a
small margin of error here.
- Tall man problems.
- And so like I've tried multiple,
like tall-fitting t-shirts,
and this is like, I can't quite,
because again, I just want
to have like a closet,
not the same color, just like, okay,
here's 10 different colors of t-shirts,
just blank t-shirts with nothing on them.
- To me, it's not about, yeah.
So it's not about, it's about fit.
It's about, you know have something.
- No, no, but it is, it's about the time,
because when you have an
issue with things fitting,
you know what's gonna happen
is you go in your closet,
and you know you're
gonna put something on,
and there's a 75% chance you're
gonna put it on and be like,
"I'm not really comfortable in this
because it's not fitting in this way."
And so you've added time to your day.
And so it is about time for me.
And so I've got these.
- And then if you run out of time,
then you might, you lack confidence.
See, that's the thing like,
because you know I'm not trying
to rub your nose in this,
but for me going into my closet is like,
"All right, I'm getting
dressed for the day.
This is my opportunity to express myself
and to embody what I'm anticipating
or what I'm feeling or
the mode I'm going into."
And if I have some new clothes,
then there's also something
to get excited about.
"Ooh, I can't wait to get
out of my pajamas today."
It's like, sometimes you
need that motivation.
So for me, it's like the self-expression,
excitement, variety of it,
but
there are times when
I'll put something on,
and I'll go in front of the mirror,
and I just won't be happy
and I'll start over.
Or I realize that that
doesn't match or whatever.
And then, and then I do get frustrated.
And if that happened to me every day
or multiple times a week,
I could start going the way of Jobs.
- Well, and I think
that it coincides with,
there's two things, there's
two sort of prevailing things
that are happening that
have led to this decision.
The first is that, the body shape thing
that I've just dealt with my entire life,
just not being a normal size.
But then the second thing is
the age that I'm at. Right?
You know? Okay.
43, even though I said
I was 42 in that sketch,
we did on Instagram because
I forgot how old I was.
I'm 43.
And,
you know, this latest iteration
of like things going back to the '90s.
And we talked about this, I
think maybe on an episode,
where I quit caring so
much about the trends
when I started realizing
that I was dressing like my children.
So I was like, okay, oh,
now I've got this like
man in my house, this
teenage man, basically,
you know, in my son Locke.
And if like we're
wearing the same clothes,
it's like something just feels off.
And, and then I'm like,
"I just kinda don't want
to keep trying that."
Like I might, like there comes a time,
I think, in most people's lives
where you just say,
"Okay, I'm checking out of
remaining with the trends."
Now, if we had stayed in North Carolina
and worked as engineers,
we would have checked out at like 24.
(laughs) You know what I'm saying?
And then you like kind of just
keep dressing the same way
for the rest of your life,
and the 25 year old engineer
and the 55 year old engineer
could trade clothes and nobody would know.
And that's a phenomenon that
happens in a lot of workplaces.
But because, "Hey, we
moved to Los Angeles,
and, oh, and we're also on the internet,
and we're trying to like
be relevant and cool."
You end up kind of wearing
things that represent like,
"Oh, these guys understand
fashion and what's in style."
And I just think my appetite
for being on that edge
is just waned over the past.
Like since I hit 40, really.
And so now I'm just like,
I'm not saying I want
to look like I don't,
I'm out of touch.
I'm just saying, find
something that fits your body
that you feel comfortable
in, that makes it look.
I mean, it looks cool, whatever, doesn't,
but it doesn't look like
you're trying to be cool.
Just looks like you are cool.
- 10 of them.
- And wear it every single day.
So I'm zeroing in on that.
Haven't figured it out yet.
- Especially if, I
mean, if it's about fit,
and then there's a number,
you can get a couple of different colors.
Like I can feel that.
All right. I've been waiting
to talk about this one.
All right, something else
that we could consider doing
to improve our lives is
to drown yourself, almost.
Could lead to lots of success
at least if you're an inventor.
Prolific inventor, Dr. Yoshiro Nakamatsu,
he patented the floppy disc in 1952,
but I didn't have to tell you that.
He's also patented over 3,300 inventions
in his 74 years on this planet.
And here's what he would do.
According to his own accounts,
many of his ideas hit him
while he was close to drowning.
Now you might think, "Well, he
just needs to be more careful
around bodies of water,"
or, you know, it's like,
"Why's this dude drowning so much?"
But he would do it intentionally
to quote, "Starve the brain
of oxygen, you must dive deep
and allow the water pressure
to deprive the brain of blood.
0.5 seconds before death.
- How do you time that?
I visualize an invention."
So he may be dramatizing this thing.
- Hold on, it says then he jots his idea
down on an underwater notepad?
- Yes.
- And swims back to the surface.
- He stays, yeah.
He's almost dying. He has the idea.
He doesn't come up (gasping),
gasps for air and say, "Oh my God,
but I've got this invention!
Give me a sheet of paper!"
No, he does that while he's still dying.
- Let me just, I mean,
listen, I don't want to.
- Underwater notepad.
- I don't want to be the skeptic here,
but if you almost die, okay.
I'm just gonna do some math here.
If you're half a second.
- 0.5.
- If you're literally
half a second from death,
and then you're still underwater,
how do you then write it down?
Doesn't the death part come?
- Doesn't really add up.
- Something about this doesn't add up,
but 3,300 inventions adds up.
- Yeah, I mean.
- The notepad part had to be made up.
This is, I don't know where you got.
I see you got the source linked there.
- That's right. 'Cause I knew
that you would be like this.
- I'm just saying that that last part
reeks of like internet creative liberties.
- Well, Rhett, it comes from the website
taogroupinc.wordpress.com
2015/06/11.
- And it's got Martha
Stewart on the website.
Okay, I take it all back. It must be true.
- Yeah.
- No, but I, okay.
But the idea of-
- Taogroup.net, cultivating growth.
- But the idea of almost dying,
I mean, I didn't.
There he is, is that him writing
on his underwater notebook?
- There's a picture of him right there.
See, he's writing.
- Everything other than
the 0.5 seconds from death.
Maybe that was just a
tidbit that he threw in.
- Maybe that's just what he feels.
Don't do this, by the way.
- Oh yeah. Please.
We'd have to tell you that. Right?
I mean, okay, so this, I mean this.
- Underwater notepad, man.
- I haven't tried this.
But there is something to the whole idea
that in fact I started watching,
there's a Netflix show that
I didn't really commit to it,
but I watch like an episode
where it's sort of that,
it's the whole, the moment of death
and all the research and ideas that come,
that moment of almost dying
and that release of DMT into the brain,
and all this stuff, and the
experiences that people have.
And I don't know what the world
view of this particular show
is, but they spend a lot
of time like talking to,
there's like a research institute
that basically just believes that, yes,
there's, your soul survives.
There's definitely life after death.
And they have all these,
they have like a compendium
of all these testimonies
of people who've experienced these things.
- "Flatliners."
- Yeah, but it made me think
about the movie "Flatliners"
for certain, but
it isn't people getting ideas,
but this made me think,
I've heard Einstein did this thing where
he would,
he said that he came up with a lot
of his sort of breakthrough ideas
in the liminal space between sleeping,
between being awakened and being asleep.
And that moment, I get, what, I don't,
there's a technical term for it.
It's like hypnagogia or hypnagote.
You know, it's, you know
the hypnagogic jerk.
I'm gonna probably say that word wrong,
but it's that I'm falling asleep,
and then you catch yourself,
and people are like it's
because we used to be in trees.
They don't really know
exactly why is happens, but.
- And if you have an underwater notepad,
and when you do that jerk,
you'll write down like an equation.
- Right. But he.
- Or if you're Keith Richards
like the riff to start me up.
- Right, yeah. So he did the same thing.
So because Einstein
- For satisfaction.
- had this happened to him so often
that he started doing this thing
where he would sit in a chair,
and he, I can't remember.
He had like a pencil that
he held above a plate.
Basically, he had this built in alarm
so that he was starting to fall asleep,
and then when he did fall asleep,
he would immediately wake himself up.
It sounds kind of like
it would drive you crazy.
But he did this multiple
times during the day
for two reasons.
Number one, he said that these many naps,
like falling asleep and
then waking up immediately,
happening over and over again in the day
was something that he needed.
He also slept like 10 hours a night.
So Einstein got a lot of sleep,
but it was also because in
that moment of falling asleep,
he was getting these insights
that he would then write down.
I mean, I haven't tried, this is.
I mean, I'm interested in it, but.
- Well, if you're, you know,
if you're doing something so heady
as like trying to solve equations
or have some sort of
breakthrough with a problem,
or yeah, it does apply to songwriting.
You know, if your entire existence
is really bent towards solving a problem
or creating something
in a very focused way,
I, you know, we do so
many different things,
but we do have problems
we're trying to solve.
And some things that
are kind of like nagging
and kinda give me anxiety.
And I wonder if there's
a way to, you know,
take a dive in my pool and think about it.
Or as I'm falling asleep, you know,
do something that's gonna wake me up
and just have an intention of
trying to solve these things.
- Well, you know what's interesting?
- Solve the problem.
- Now that we're talking about this,
I do, it has hit me
that while in the sauna at
these really high temperatures,
I'll be listening.
I usually put on a podcast or
a book or something like that.
And I feel like I'm
having some higher level
of insight into something,
and I'll come up with an idea,
and I'll get out and I'll, I need to,
like a sweat-proof notebook.
Because I mean like going out,
'cause I can't bring my phone
in there 'cause it's too hot.
- Sweat-proof notebook.
- And then I like wipe my
hands off and type something.
- You need a Yoshiro Nakamatsu.
- He's probably, probably
that one would probably work.
The underwater pad would
also work as a sweat pad,
but there's this other book I was reading.
I can't remember what it was,
but the guy was talking about
how there's a bunch of thinkers
in history who have insisted
that walking is how
you come up with ideas,
that you've got to be in
motion in order to like,
a bunch of people.
It was like, he quotes all these people.
I was like I've never thought about this.
I mean, I've had ideas while walking
and sometimes you're like,
"I need to, let me take a walk on this."
Well, I don't know the science behind it,
but the idea that you're in motion,
you kind of get your body and your mind
kind of doing something, and
then something cracks open.
- Well, I mean, my theory is,
yeah, I like to do a lot of thinking
when I'm like riding my mountain bike.
I've started doing that more
often, just kind of taking,
found this one trail I can
do in less than an hour,
and I know the trail, and I
know it increasingly better.
So I can devote more of my
active attention to just not die,
not to dying or falling off the cliff,
or you know, where my tire
is, but on other things.
But the way that I
think about those things
is it's a little bit different
than I would think about them
if I was just sitting down at my desk
trying to solve the problem or
trying to work something out.
You know, it's, it ruminates.
And I think, you know,
when you're in your body,
I do think that you think differently.
- Oh, yeah.
- And so you can approach
problems differently,
or a creative exercise differently.
So it, but, 'cause for me, a lot of times,
I've noticed, you know,
you get so much in your head about,
well, I need to accomplish this,
or I gotta solve this problem,
or I really want to create
this thing right now.
And then it's kind of self-defeating
when you're just 100%
focused on it, there's a,
because then you have
all this self-awareness
of like the pressure you put on yourself,
but if you're doing something else,
or it kind of relieves that
pressure, at least for me,
to say, "You know, I don't
have to solve this right now."
So I can kind of play with the idea.
It's the difference between
working with an idea
and playing with an idea.
And so I don't know any of
the science really behind it,
but I've observed
that
the best solutions or ideas
come from left field when
you when you least expect it,
or when you give room
and remove the pressure
of having to show improve.
- I kind of experienced
it as a balance between,
like if I sit down, and I'm like,
okay, I need to write this thing.
And like, okay, this, you know,
I need to write 20 pages.
I like, and you kind of have to,
there is sort of a work
sort of focus that happens.
And I tend to be like, all right.
I, you know, there's certain problems
that I'm gonna come to in this process.
There are certain holes,
and there certain unanswered questions.
But when I come to those
unanswered questions,
I'm not going to spend a lot of time
just sitting there thinking
about the solution.
I'm going to arrive at a
solution, put it as a placeholder.
Maybe it ends up being the final decision,
and then I'm gonna keep moving.
And that way I'll be able to say,
hey, you sat down for two
hours, and you wrote this much,
but then what I'll find
is if I've done that,
if I've laid the track,
and that track has some
problems in it, right?
Then when I'm doing something
completely unrelated
like sitting in the sauna,
thinking about something else,
listening to something else,
all of a sudden the
solution to that problem,
that I created a hole.
And then all of a sudden,
the solution to the problem pops in
in those other spaces.
And then I go back into that.
Now I'm back into work mode.
And I take that solution that came to me
in a different phase, in
sort of the play phase.
So that,
I mean, I have never
thought about that being,
I don't do that intentionally.
It's just as you talk about
it, I realize that's what I do
naturally is just to kind
of be like, all right,
I could sit here for the next 30 minutes
thinking about this one problem,
but I'm a little bit ADHD,
so I'm gonna end up
getting on the internet
or doing something else.
But if I just be like,
nope, just move past that.
Get to the next thing,
the solution to that will come later
while you're doing something else,
like walking, riding the
bike, in the sauna, whatever.
- As long as you don't start breathing
before you come up for air.
- That's the key.
- Yeah. I didn't say that.
That is how your Yoshiro Nakamatsu died.
He drowned.
- Oh, he really?
- Yeah. He drowned.
I wonder what he was coming up with.
It must've been so good,
he couldn't come up.
I'm lying about that.
No source.
Link is the source.
- Hold on, so you're saying
he might still be alive.
- Yeah.
- Well, okay.
- 'Cause you can black out pretty easily,
and you definitely shouldn't
do anything like that.
First of all, just don't do it.
But if you are gonna try to
do like holding your breath,
don't do it by yourself.
Do it in the presence of someone else
who can pull you out of the water.
- I got another one for you.
This is especially for you.
Pythagoras, you know, with his
theorem and all that stuff.
I dunno from like 500 BC, give or take.
Greek mathematician.
He, I didn't know this about him,
but he's credited with
popularizing a meatless lifestyle,
dubbed the father of vegetarianism.
So, you know, he was this,
you know, he was a mathematician,
but it was, there was so
much philosophy and politics,
and, you know, all of these
thinkers, Greek thinkers
and philosophers and
mathematicians and astronomers.
You know, we're figuring
all this stuff out
and thinking about all of these things.
But a lot of it was very contentious,
as I'll get to in a second.
But even though he did not eat meat,
he just ate veggies, he hated beans.
He hated lagoons.
And he had, you know, he had followers.
He had people that he was teaching
and that were like learning from him.
And I guess being
allegiant to his beliefs.
He even forbade them from
eating or touching beans.
- What's wrong with this guy?
- We don't know if it was for
health or religious reasons,
but here's what happened.
That he did die.
He is no longer alive, Pythagoras.
- Yep. I guess that.
- And there's all these different
accounts of how he died.
One of them, which I'll call a legend
is that there were these
attackers who attacked a house
that he and some of his followers were in
for, I mean, again for
that political contention,
and it got to the point where
they were killing people.
And as he fled
his, this house,
he was getting away.
But then he encountered a bean field,
and he refused to run
through the bean field.
And then, so he was caught
by the attackers and killed.
- He got what he deserved.
(Link laughs)
This is ridiculous.
- So if you want to be a
successful mathematician,
you should avoid beans.
- I never liked the Pythagorean theorem.
I always questioned it.
A squared plus B squared equals C squared?
- I did hear the question
mark as you said it.
- I mean, it's like really?
- Yeah, really.
- Really?
- Yes. Yes.
- I don't know.
- Yes.
- I honestly don't know.
- It is a theorem.
- This is strange.
This is a strange, this
is a strange position.
I understand the not eating meat. Okay.
But most people who don't eat meat.
- It's weird that they.
- Who sell the idea to me are like,
well, you can eat beans all
the time kinda as a substitute.
- Yeah, mental flaws could not
tell me why he hated beans,
but there is this whole
health meets religion meets.
You know, all of these
ideas are floating around.
All of these ideas are
floating around. Yeah.
I mean,
- Fava beans.
- I could see, what about them?
- I think that was the field.
- Oh.
(Link laughs)
I got this.
- You want to know how to do
triangle math, avoid the beans.
We don't need to talk about it anymore.
We can move on.
- I just wanted you to know, Rhett.
- Well, no, but I feel like I got this.
I'm not gonna say what brand it is
because I don't know what
I think about them yet,
but they've got a bunch of fake meat.
And again,
the principle of eating
less meat, I'm all on board.
I get it. I understand the
impact on the environment.
And so, and also just
the impact on lifestyle.
So the idea of minimizing meat intake
is something that I'm
personally interested in.
The fact that I like beans
makes that somewhat easier.
- The idea is something
you're personally interested.
The practice is a little more difficult.
- The practice is more difficult because.
- Because of the whole meat part of it.
Yeah. I'm with you, man.
- Well, here, okay.
I'll be honest with you.
I'm kind of holding out for fake meat,
like real fake meat, like lab-grown meat,
like meat that's actually meat,
but that was grown in a lab.
Because they're gonna be able to do that
with so much less environmental impact.
And obviously it's gonna
be considerably more humane
because it won't require
slaughtering any animals.
- And by not becoming a
vegetarian or vegan, we both.
- I can make it to that,
can cross that bridge.
- Well, we're actually
creating an environment
where that can succeed.
We're making an incentive.
We're incentivizing them.
- 'Cause you're not gonna get the world
to just decide to stop eating meat.
You might be able to
get the lab-grown meat.
- Right.
That's why I keep eating meat
to demonstrate the
demand for meatless meat.
- This is quite a theory.
- That's what I'm doing.
I'm doing, I'm long.
This is a long play for the environment.
- Okay. Well, I appreciate that.
But I got this meat
that's made from beans.
And this doesn't happen when
I do like an Impossible Burger
or like Beyond Meat.
I don't think it happens, but I got this.
- Are you gonna talk about poo-poo?
- This meat that had been made
with beans and other things,
and they send you like
a pack of it and it's,
there's taco meat, there's sausages,
there's hamburgers, all
these different fake meats.
And you know I like to do the
scramble thing on the weekend.
I'll make a scramble for my wife and I.
That's not correct grammar by the way.
Be my wife and me.
- I'm losing you. I'm losing you, man.
- But I made this taco scramble
with this fake taco meat.
- Didn't work.
- And the whole weekend,
it was just this past
weekend, Saturday and,
I came over to your
house on Saturday night,
I didn't want to talk about it.
You know, but I was in like bloat pain
the whole time I was there.
- You were grimacing.
- It was just like very
bloated, very like not.
And I guess maybe you
would adjust over time,
but I eat a fair amount of beans.
It's just, it's like why
is it the human body?
If the human body is supposed
to only eat vegetables,
then why is it so difficult
for me to digest the vegetables?
- Well, it's because
you wear hoodies, man.
It's the same thing.
It's like the brown fat's gonna go away.
You gotta get used to it.
- You're saying I'm maladjusted.
- You're soft.
- I'm maladjusted.
But what's your point?
- Just I'm saying, I want
to not make a full switch,
but I want to minimize meat.
- I want to eat some
- But the fake meat,
- of that meat on the GMM.
- the lab grown meat,
the lab grown meat is where,
and I know it's gonna be
difficult to convince people
'cause they're all scared
of things from a lab,
but we'll get there, we'll get there.
- I wanted to put one in
here that wasn't so strange,
but I just thought it was
so personally impactful.
- Speaking of impactful,
that's a Sunday afternoon, man.
All those beans came out.
- One of the things,
One of the habits that you can incorporate
into your life that I have incorporated,
this made a difference
that's popped up on these
lists that we looked at,
was me-time or according
to one Ted speaker
named Steven Kotler, he calls it non-time.
I did not watch the Ted talk
because I read this sentence,
and that's all I needed to know.
He discusses the importance of downtime
that is just for you, and here's the key.
It doesn't require you to
think about anything at all.
Einstein did this, Steve jobs did this.
Dwayne The Rock Johnson wakes
up early for a quiet time.
Now we woke up early for quiet times,
or at least that's what we.
- But it meant something very specific.
- Yeah, that was like a.
- Bible study and prayer time.
- Yeah, it was a Christian
spiritual exercise.
Now.
- And we also weren't very good at it.
- Not very consistent.
Now,
that sometime, I have me-time.
I aim to have me-time every morning.
I'm such a, you know,
I have this sense of
what I ought to be doing.
And I certainly have this sense of like
if I'm not meeting my own
expectations as a perfectionist.
And so I always have this, you know,
that voice in my head that's like
should I be doing something different?
Should I be doing, should I
be doing better than this?
Am I meeting my standard? You know?
Am I contributing?
Or am I being lazy or whatever
the case may be? You know?
So it's actually scheduling
time where the goal and the task
is to do nothing,
have no obligations.
So, you know, I set my
alarm 30 minutes earlier,
and then I'll go down,
I'll drink my coffee.
And I'll just sit on the couch.
Now when I'm done with my coffee
or done with enough of my coffee
that like I'm ready to
move on to the next thing,
that's when I like
actually do a meditation.
And I do consider meditation
as part of this me-time,
because, I mean,
the practice of mindfulness
meditation is to.
- To not think.
- To not think
or to acknowledge the
thoughts that you're having,
but not to obligate yourself
to engage in those thoughts.
So it gives you space.
It gives you head space.
Now actually it's, HeadSpace
is gonna be a sponsor on
"Good Mythical Morning."
It's not as sponsor here, but, I mean,
I've tried lots of
different meditation apps,
and they're all good
for different reasons,
but Headspace is a great introductory one.
And I'm glad that they're a sponsor.
Again, they're not a sponsor right now,
but since I'm talking about
it, and if you are interested,
you can use our code EAR.
You gotta, it's headspace.com/ear.
And then you got to put
in the coupon code EAR
to get, I can't remember
what it is right now.
- It's a good deal.
- It's a deal.
And it helps us, and, anyway.
I'm not great at it.
And we've talked about it in the past,
and how we've, you know, you get into it.
You have seasons of
being in and out of it,
but whether you're actually learning
and practicing mindfulness meditation,
or if you're just taking
time to where it's like,
you know what, I'm drinking my
tea, I'm drinking my coffee.
I'm just gonna sit here.
And I'm just going to notice myself.
I'm gonna notice what it feels like.
I'm gonna notice if I'm, you know,
am I experiencing anxiety
or what, you know,
whatever the case may be,
and just give yourself freedom
to just not have to engage.
With the way my brain works,
I really do think it's
making a huge difference
in my capacity to then go on with my life
for the rest of the day.
- Yeah, it's really tough for
me to do it in the morning.
I think I've replaced it.
And I know most of the time
I am listening to something,
but like I'm getting that like half hour
every, pretty much every day in the sauna.
And I've thought about
making that into meditation,
but it's almost the
heat is so intense that-
- You need a distraction.
- I need something to kind of focus on.
But it is a very meditative time.
And when I get out of the thing
kind of in between them
and the pool, whatever,
but I've been working out in the morning,
and there was a time when I was meditating
and then working out,
and it's just like,
I have to get up so early
in order to come to,
my workout is like an hour.
And so it's so tough, but.
- But that's what it is for me.
Are you saying, 'cause I was,
I did want to just flat out ask,
you know, what is the one practice
that you would point to for you personally
that is the key to your either success
or personal wellbeing,
if you were to nail it down to one thing?
I think for me, it is that me-time.
And then I think a corollary
is beginning to see exercise
as something that allows me to,
to get out of my head
and get into my body.
And so it's not just
about all the other things
you associate with working
out, but it's just about,
it gives my brain a
break to actually engage
in rigorous physical activity.
So I think that's my answer.
- Well,
I mean, one thing before I give
you my answer is, you know,
Eckhart Tolle talks about how mindfulness
is kind of a misnomer, that
it's actually a mistranslation,
because his whole deal is about
how the mind is the problem.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
thoughts and your mind feeling
like it has to be active
and it has to be doing something
and identifying yourself
with your mind is like the key
to all suffering essentially.
Him does a much better
way of talking about it.
He's also, his voice is very intoxicating,
but so mindfulness is
actually about not thinking.
Like, yeah, the reason that
you focus on your breath
or you observe a thought is
actually so you won't think
about those things and you
won't go down a rabbit trail.
And that's why you keep
bringing your thoughts back
to your breath, so you don't think.
And I,
and so, I mean, I find meditation
to be very helpful in that
even though it's so difficult
for me to stop thinking.
Because even when I do meditation
I keep reframing it according
to how well I'm meditating,
or, you know, it's like,
this is a very common problem
for anybody trying to
gets into meditation.
- If that makes you feel better.
- And so, but what I found is that
I have to because I'm forced
to because of my back.
I have to every single
morning, I have to get up,
and now I go down to,
'cause we've kind of
redone the garage area,
and it's kind of like a gym,
and I've got like a yoga mat down there,
I play some like peaceful music,
some like Spotify meditation playlist.
You know, I've got so many,
and I know I keep promising
putting this on the site,
and I will someday, but my stretching
sort of yoga sort of back
essential routine every single day
is about 20 minutes every single day.
And so, and I'm not thinking
about anything at that point,
other than what I'm doing to my body,
you know what I'm saying?
It's just like I'm stretching in this way.
I'm stretching in this way.
I'm doing this move. I'm doing that move.
And I'm playing this music or whatever.
So I think that's kind of
become my meditation time.
And I have to do that in
order to stay healthy,
but I also have to do that
in order to then work out
without hurting myself.
So it ends up being about an
hour and a half total time
every day pretty much
of doing the, you know,
half, 20 minutes or so of the stretching
and then like a workout
that's about an hour long.
I think that that's
become pretty essential,
and it's become so, so much
of a rhythm in quarantine,
that I'm kind of nervous
about life going back
to the way that it was.
I mean, a lot of people have
been talking about this lately.
They're like, oh, now that life seems like
it's about to return to normal,
and, you know, everybody's
gonna be vaccinated.
And then we're gonna
start doing all the things
that we were doing before,
there's this anxiety that a
lot of people are having about,
some people is a social anxiety.
Like I haven't been in a crowd.
I'm kinda nervous about that.
I don't, that's not me.
That's not how I think about it.
I think I have an anxiety
about being pulled out of these rhythms
that I've been able to establish,
that like, yeah, okay, if
we go to New York City,
I can do the back routine
on the hotel floor, right?
But if you want to work out, you're like,
well, I'm gonna go to the hotel gym
and what are they gonna have,
and, oh, what am I gonna do at night?
I can't go, I can't go get my sauna.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like, these are privileged problems,
but I just have this anxiety about not,
this has become such a part
of my existence at this point.
I haven't thought about it in
these terms, in this non-time.
But I think it's probably
one of the reasons
that I feel good right now.
I feel kind of healthy
because I've got these things
that I'm doing almost every single day
that are pretty consistent
and not focused on doing,
doing, doing, doing.
- I think that's why now is a good time
to have this conversation because
as things start to change,
it's like, okay, is there
something new to incorporate
or something that you started
to incorporate that you want,
that there's a new priority
associated with it,
that you're gonna protect that, you know?
I hope that's true
of me, that I'll keep getting
up and taking that time.
- Well, I mean, the good
news for me is the fact
that I have, like, if I
don't do the stretching,
I literally can't go on about my day.
Like I will, I'll be in pain
for the rest of the day.
So that's kind of the blessing
of a lower back injury
or chronic pain or whatever it is.
Is that, okay, like if we're
traveling, and we're like,
okay, we gotta be at this
interview at seven o'clock,
or something like that, I'm like,
okay, well, I've got to get up.
I've got to have at least
20 minutes to sit there
and do these stretches,
and you can't go faster
than the stretches allow.
And so I guess that's a good thing.
Sometimes there's, you know, pain can be,
an inconvenience can be
a blessing if you turn it
into something that ends up
being sort of meditative.
- #EarBiscuits, let us know
if any of that resonates with you.
You got a rec for us?
- I do.
- Sweet.
- This is gonna be in the
category of things that are old
or least not current
that most of you probably
didn't watch when it was around,
and so maybe like me and you,
you can discover it for the first time,
the HBO show "The Watchman,"
based on the graphic novel,
which was probably the only
graphic novel I've ever read.
And I really liked it.
This is, I mean, what?
It's been like four years or so that this?
Three years?
- I don't think it's that old.
Of course we've been in LA for 10 years.
I wouldn't have believed that either.
- But, hold on.
There's only, is it, there was only,
there was only one season.
It was like a limited series, right?
Or is it, or is there
gonna be a second season?
- I haven't heard about
a second season. No.
- Okay, well maybe it's not
as old as I thought it was,
and maybe there isn't gonna be
a second season, but anyway,
excellent television show.
And the same thing that
happened to me happened to you
when you were watching it
which is halfway through the season,
you began to think is this?
It started really good.
And then halfway through the season,
you're kind of like is this
getting to be too complex?
How are they gonna
bring this all together?
And I don't like super complex shows.
And so I'll end up,
I started to almost kind of lose interest,
and then the way it all came together
in the last two episodes
was just some of the best
television that I've ever seen.
- I would say that the penultimate episode
was one of my favorite episodes of a show.
It's the first episode of
a show that I've watched,
and then I sat down the next night
and I watched that same episode again,
before, even though I
could go to the finale.
- And the way that it weaves-
- And that redeemed
the whole thing for me.
Because the season as a whole,
- Well, I thought that.
- I'm like it's really good,
but that was just mind blowing.
- The second to last episode was so good
that I thought that the season was over,
and I told Jessie, I was
like, "That was incredible!"
She was like, "What about that storyline
and that storyline and that storyline?
Isn't there gonna be?"
I was like, "Oh yeah, there's probably,"
and then we were like, "Oh
yeah, there is another episode."
But the way that they kind of explore
these science fiction
concepts in a fresh way,
but then also weave in the
issues of racial justice
in a way that doesn't
feel reaching or forced.
You know, a lot of times
people might be like,
well, I'm gonna do this thing,
and it's gonna have this
social justice issue in it.
And I'm gonna do it in a way
that feels preachy or whatever.
They do it in a way
that is very compelling
and very relevant to the
story and very effective
and just makes it that
much better of a story.
So "The Watchman" on HBO.
HBO just, I mean, they've
been a sponsor before.
They do so many things right.
- I like HBO, man.
- Just do it right.
- All right, y'all.
We'll keep talking.
Every day is this
another day of your life.
Thanks for making us a
part of some of those.
- That's true.
And once a week, let us
be a part of your life.
Well, on this show,
and there's another show
pretty much every day.
You know, there's a lot of
stuff, a lot of content.
- Let us just take over your life.
(rhythmic music)
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(rhythmic music)